hey what's up you guys i'm denny direct
oh we are live on ET facebook page with
one of my favorites ultra cephalo
different hair color this yeah I've got
to my natural you are back to your
natural brow thank you um so as always
there's so much to talk to you about
will be also taking fan questions so
while we're chatting you guys please
leave them in the comments section below
we'll get to as many as possible um but
I mean you have a new book coming out so
I know it's so crazy how excited are you
I know you've been working on this for
what like two years now
yeah well concept like the story
building into my head to like actually
making it come to life it's been a it's
been a process but I'm so happy that
it's finally done and I'm so [ __ ]
nervous are you able to read it because
it's like I mean more nervous than my
first book I think because that was my
life like it is what it is this is a
story that I'm just like I love and I'm
so passionate about and just to have
people read this like creative baby is
so frightening cuz it's like permanent
it's not like online where you can like
to leave us like there are thousands of
copies around the world like you can't
disappear from that and like people are
already pre ordering it like they're
gonna get their hands on this and Rita
and you're right cuz it's your first
young adult like fiction yeah right it's
something I've wanted to for so long
like I've I think since I was like a kid
yeah I was like maybe one day I'll you
know it's like with my own story so let
me ask you this have you always had this
particular story in your mind like were
you always dying to write this story not
this one in particular this has been
something in the past like a few years
that's been bringing my mind but it
never was like a book idea it was always
like what's gonna be my first movie um
and then I was like you know a lot of
people wanted a storytellers book and I
was like well I can't really do a
storytellers book because the series is
already out like it would be weird to go
back to a book so I decided to start
with the book and then possibly it would
eventually get me into a movie if you
guys don't know the premise which I want
you to explain to them this feels like
it could be a movie like an alter well
that's what I was imagining during
processor creating it so tell us about
the world you created in these
characters um so I was inspired by uh
China's one-child policy which doesn't
exist anymore but I just like was so
fascinated by that idea of like limiting
families to one child so I decided to
create this dystopian it's not even like
I just Oh penis honestly where our
future is headed it for continued in
this direction it is freaks me out
thinking about those things but it's so
fascinating to um so basically humanity
has destroyed itself but this guy Aaron
Alba's creates this city of Eden which
is kind of like humanity's last chance
of survival so it's like a
self-sustaining city but because
resources have diminish from the world
the government puts in place laws where
families can only have one child to keep
resources and keep humanity alive so it
follows a girl who's born a twin and her
family decides to keep her hidden so her
whole life is just like hidden behind
these walls and um one night she just
can't take it anymore and the story
unfolds from there tell me that doesn't
sound like a movie like I mean obviously
it's gonna be a fantastic novel too but
man there's so much potential now
Hollywood you hear that a great story um
how much fun was you creating that world
again cuz this is just coming from your
like your imagination right and that's
what I love to do I just love to just
like have these crazy thoughts come to
my head but the hardest part about it is
deciding like where you want it go to UM
cuz like every choice you make like
decides the rest of the story
so like one wrong move and it could go
in a totally different direction um so I
think that was the scariest part of it
all the scariest part was not letting
your imagination kind of get the best of
you and going like or like having two
ideas than like having decide for your
hair achter like what decision is she
going to make sure you've always been
such a good storyteller and obviously
super creative like at what point did
you realize you wanted to do it all not
just videos on YouTube but also like
write a book for example um I don't know
I think it's just like I've always had
imagination which kind of goes into my
real life like it's a blessing and a
curse at the same time sometimes I think
my life is a movie at points and I think
like I hear a noise and like downstairs
kitchen I'm like oh my god okay so the
murderers down there all right what's my
plan of escape and like I just come up
with this whole thing in my head of like
what the scenario is gonna be um or like
I'll just be out walking the park and
I'll just see a whole scene taking place
I don't know that's just like how my
brain works but it can be accurst
because I think people are out to get me
or something
you're like there is a yeah that guy
examine the corner like no I love that
though they're already getting so many
comes to people who say and they just
can't wait and if they pre-ordered your
ball thank you awesome
but the best part about this is on the
book release which is October 4th and
also uh you've also created a short film
for the first chapter yeah yeah um so
basically I going back to the whole
wanting it to be a movie thing I'm I'm a
very visual person so like when I was
thinking of like ways to promote the
book I was like I want to make like a
short film and I was coming up with
ideas of like something in the same
universe but not from the book but that
I was like you know what I'm just gonna
go for the first chapter and try and
recreate that but of course like not
having a movie budget to recreate my
vision was very difficult yeah some
things are a little bit different and
that's just because like it's impossible
to find the set that I've created a
reasonable price without creating a
whole entire set because it's like a
Steven Spielberg movie in your you know
in what's your dream director and dream
actor for this oh no I can't I'm well
aware of that no no I don't yeah so
you're open to any I am so open okay
yeah
cuz you want to be pigeonholed you want
to exactly yeah okay so were you working
on this while you were shooting and
writing like a skip tonight for this oh
yeah yeah I I have my life many projects
going on at the same time I mean talk
about two different worlds though yeah I
was up for you though and people
I brought into these worlds um I mean
it's so it's so fun like just getting to
bounce around a different world and
stuff going from like murder mystery to
like dystopian yeah like also working on
storyteller season two like I have like
three projects that I'm like okay wait
no there's no magic in this world
there's but they're also so different
that they can't how do you tell me could
they ever be like could be a cross you
know senator yeah I'm so separate
separate but equal' separately odd so
storytellers are second season it's
happening right yeah yep awesome and
then works with legendary yes yeah I
mean escape tonight and he talks about
like bringing that back maybe yeah where
it definitely in talks about season two
coming up with some ideas and whatnot
it's definitely not confirmed yet but
fingers crossed everything works out
there I love it I have a couple fan
questions already
okay look at do it we mentioned you have
brown hair now yes uh Kelsey wants to
know have you ever regretted dyeing your
hair a certain color and you had a lot
of moment you got so many okay um I do
regret getting my facial hair colored I
dye it green and it just burnt it wasn't
like the burning of the face it was the
burning of the fumes because I like
didn't realize it's like oh I can handle
like burn but I didn't realize like the
fumes were so close to my face like it
in my eyes like I was like what breathe
like do i freed from my mouth or my nose
like it all her terrible yeah so don't
do that it's like when you cut an onion
except I'm sure it's like times ten
maybe yeah like really bad it's nothing
bleach for 20 minutes is probably not
that's right Katie wants to know who
inspires you the most in life inspires
me up um recently I'm like super
inspired by Elon Musk well I think he's
so incredible like I always say he's
like our Savior
like truly I have like so much respect
for him he's like trying to make a
difference in this world so I just
support him in every way I love that
that make sense to me if you had three
wishes from Harrison I love this
question if you've got three wishes from
a magic lamp
what could you wish for world peace
first wish would be it to live in like a
super cool modern castle so it looked
super like medieval on the outside but
on the inside it was like super modern
and like really cute yeah side and so
you can have a room just full of your
crystals right that's my second one a
room entirely made of crystals
it's a cave within the castle I want
secret passages I want water slides all
the things that anyone would want in a
castle you want like your escape the
night set but for reals where you live
yeah but not not that scary but oh
that's scary guys no no no place I can
hang out yeah I like watch Netflix oh my
gosh
third wish would be it to have some sort
of superpower to like be able to like
bend water at my will or like just be
telekinesis not invisible I think
telekinesis because I want to show off
my power I don't want to like be a hit
and I'm sure that says something about
my personality
Georgia Watts no who's the funniest
person on the escape tonight set how do
you even choose that because ah
characters it has to be glozell like she
was making me laugh during filming I was
like this is a serious moment cause I'll
stop singing out of nowhere like yeah
truly it was so funny
Alex wants to know what's your favorite
part of writing um I guess just like the
freedom the freedom of just getting to
create any thought you have and bring it
to life it's just like it's cool it's
scary at the same time but also it's
like no one's telling you no right you
get to just like free your mind to
explore your imagination and it's really
fun you also have like a very creative
platform to spread a message you know
and is there is there something you want
fans to take away from this particular
book um yeah I put a lot of seeds to be
planted about how we're treating the
planet so there's a lot of that
within the story it's not just a like
dystopian thing it's like okay this
could actually happen to our world so
let's make sure this does it so you
don't have to go through what my main
character realms are going through let's
not let sound let that happening guys
let's save the planet I we have so many
questions are you down yeah okay uh
let's see Amanda oh no no Bernice
monster are you having another leg for
the book tour
that's a good question um so we're
working on dates um yeah I'm just
waiting to hear back like I
unfortunately have no control over the
tours it's all publisher slash
bookstores and sales guys right
pre-sales themselves by the book you're
out of the book right now while you're
watching us though let's see uh Kristen
Wilson oh you and Daniel are so cute and
I think is also so cute uh what's your
favorite thing about being in a
long-term relationship um you know I've
been single my whole life he's my first
boyfriend ever so um I think just not
having to be in the dating scene I think
is like the best part cuz I feel like I
got into this mode of just disconnecting
myself from like having that one-on-one
thing so I could never like connect with
someone long enough so it felt like I
was constantly one guy to the next
casual dating um but it's just nice to
have someone that you can rely on and
like if you're sick he can take care of
you make you breakfast in the morning
what advice you have for single guys
like I don't know this guy oh my gosh I
don't know I think um just make sure
that you're ready with yourself because
I feel like a lot of people try to get
into relationships when they're not
fully ready themselves and that I think
subconsciously makes anything fail well
said yeah and it's worth the wait
clearly Ryu and Daniel look super happy
yeah the
one question from Kelsey what's your
excuse me Angelina what's your favorite
thing to do together um favorite thing
to do do you guys like go out to dinner
do ya I mean like yeah the normal stuff
are you outdoors guys yeah ya are
um I think mostly just like hanging with
the dogs and just like being casual but
also we travel a lot which is really fun
um we went to Japan last year no this
year oh my gosh oh I want to go back so
bad but you do yeah I got I've never
been oh my god you fell in love I like I
feel like I left a piece of my soul when
I loved like I need to go back you'll be
back doing X Y s all right well you guys
thanks so much for sending your
questions and the book is out October
for children of Eden you could pre-order
it now right yeah can't wait to see the
short film
thanks for coming hang out with us all
if you guys haven't already which if
you're watching I'm sure you have make
sure you go subscribe to Joey's YouTube
channel and also be sure to subscribe to
e t--'s Facebook page so you can watch
more of these fun Facebook live so we
can bring more like jovian exactly all
right you guys take care we'll see you
next time